you asked and we are going to deliver
the xiaomi 12s ultra lycophone versus
the vivo x80 pro with the zeiss optics
in it both of these phones got a lot of
hype out there in terms of their cameras
but which one is one of the best camera
phones of 2022 for the android system
let's find out right now
[Music]
all right so talking about this camera
system of course we've got a vario
sumicron lens setup in here and a brand
new one-inch sensor this is a sensor
we've never seen on any other camera
phone before it's a proprietary sensor
designed for the xiaomi 12-s ultra if
you look at the back of the phone you'll
actually see a very large camera in the
center and you might be thinking well
isn't that the main leica camera the one
inch sensor camera no that's the wide
the one inch sensor is on the left of it
which is a little bit odd in terms of
design language i would have figured
that like and xiaomi would have wanted
it to have that camera front and center
and have the ultra wide and the macro
lens or telephoto lens around that but
it is what it is um okay so let's talk
about this leica quality what is the
leica look
and if we go back in time actually the
leica look came from the lenses because
film was filmed based on the film stock
every film body was relatively the same
of course like it was built with brass
but we could arguably say a better made
body than a lot of other camera systems
out there but it was the lenses that
kept leica separate from a lot of the
competitors out there and made them very
special as we come into the digital
world though
then it became what the sensor was able
to produce and then of course the
processor and one of the cameras that
still to this day collectors love the
colors of was the m9 ccd sensor was
designed with kodak and it almost had a
kodachrome look to it which is beautiful
to this day people still buy that camera
for the look the colors that
quote-unquote leica look now like has
since adopted new sensors new technology
and the colors have changed quite
significantly but they're still
relatively that same color science which
is more vibrancy reds are very strong
greens are prominent you're going to
notice it with a number of the sample
images we're showing you here throughout
this video the reds stand out that's
absolutely beautiful
the greens the greenery the lush the
landscapes if you want to capture that
you're going to really enjoy it blues
pop it's really the vibrancy that really
comes alive now when we go into the
black and white modes here of course
when you shoot in jpeg you have all
these settings inside the sl2 for
example but when you go into black and
white it does remind me a little bit of
the monochrome series from leica the q
the m series now those cameras were
designed with a monochrome sensor only
no color
that was taken out of the camera
altogether
it's not a filter the sensor was a black
and white sensor and that is some of the
best black and white photographer you
will ever see out of any camera to date
coming out of those monochrome systems
now of course they don't have that here
in this xiaomi 12s ultra but what they
do have is something relatively very
similar to the profile that we're seeing
here in the sl2 and other leica cameras
that you shoot in jpeg now when you
shoot in raw you're not going to get any
of that so i will be showing you sample
images from the sl2 with the 50 f2
summicron
versus the 12s ultra just for fun but
obviously this will be a much better
optical setup than the 12s ultra but to
give you an idea in terms of the color
profile what it looks like out of a
leica camera versus what it looks like
out of the 12s ultra so what else is
inside this camera that makes it unique
well of course you have these various
different filters like vivid natural
authentic black and white black and
white high contrast you've got a lot of
these profiles that are built inside of
it which make it really good and of
course the lenses the lenses are
absolutely astounding now of course the
main camera sensor the one-inch sensor
will have the best lens in my personal
opinion it is sharp you have less
ghosting less flaring than i've seen on
any other smartphone thus far it is
optically beautiful and we're also going
to be comparing it to the x80 pro
because that has a zeiss setup inside of
it zeiss lenses leica lenses how do they
fare with each other you might be
surprised at the results of this but i
will tell you this out of all the camera
phones i've tested thus far the main
sensor out of this thing
is the most impressive i've used up to
this point in 2022. so
we've now come to the point we're going
to show you comparison side by side of
images x80 pro versus the 12s ultra
check out this montage we're back with
you with our final thoughts
[Music]
[Applause]
so as we saw from the photos in that
montage both of these images are
relatively really good now the edge in
terms of clarity in terms of resolving
power in terms of depth of field
i'm going to give it to the xiaomi leica
that one inch sensor does definitely
make a difference
the vivo also has its own
character its own genesecua i mean it's
that it's that nice color it's a little
bit more muted a little bit more
cinematic
and there's times that i really like
what the zeiss camera is doing but again
that one inch sensor is absolutely
beautiful in terms of lower light up uh
situations in terms of uh reduction
flaring because of the lenses i mean the
video that you're seeing right here i
really like it now the color can be
toned down a little bit and sometimes in
my personal opinion and that's something
that you can do in post but it is for
the most part the camera system to beat
in 2022 thus far at least for the main
camera but the vivo x80 pro does have
it's uh his charm and so for those of
you on the fence i mean of course in
terms of optical quality i'm going to
give it to the leica xiaomi phone the 12
is ultra
but this zeiss phone is no slouch in its
own right and especially with firmware
updates coming through they're going to
be improving the camera system i'm sure
some of these bokeh effects will get
better over time and this is also a very
fun phone so anyway guys those are my
thoughts on the 12s ultra and the x80
pro which one would you rather have let
me know in the comment section below if
you want to see our vivo x80 pro review
click right here on our other smartphone
camera reviews we'll also be listed here
as well